basically silver medalists and the tech
world in the town acquisition world are
people who gather very last Finish Line
or is not getting the job so we all know
it right we all recruited before we all
been recruited to specific jobs we we
hear this sentence of
it's between you and another person
we're just not true yet we need to
figure it out and then one person is
being picked and the other one is a
silver medalist right second place and
there are tons of other really really
good opportunities for those Talent out
there so our solution is basically
combining the efforts between all the
companies on the platform on those
silver medalists that they have allowing
those talent to tap into really good
opportunities within other companies
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20-minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures Jay Ventures
Riverside of Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctek
[Music]
thank you very very much for joining me
all the way from New York from junco um
really a pleasure to have you here and
talking about
underrepresented Talent recruitment
diversification in general a with what
you're doing today so so it's going to
be a really interesting 20 minutes for
me
would love to dive into your journey so
so Elite tell me a little bit about you
know yourself and and how you got into
this whole world
yeah
um so most of my career have been on the
tech side of of stuff outside of my
career in 8200
um as an engineer then I left moved to
product management
um being in computer science I didn't be
in London so nothing that has to do with
what we do today
um and
at some point in the end of my career is
like I see
um I joined the group of female and
private management and started to be
more exposed to
gaps in the industry that I was not
aware of I think there are the gaps that
everyone talks about which is like
salary gaps and promotion gaps but
through this group I became more and
more aware of
how challenging it is to recruit more
other representative minorities and the
little and small things that happened
along the way that makes it so
challenging for them to stick within a
corporation and grow
um and it was kind of like an
intersection between this knowledge that
I came across and my appetite to start
my own thing
um I wanted it to be both with an impact
angle but also interestingly for me from
a technology and product
um angle and this is how I end up here
I love it and so take me to the world
where junco was born what what is this
world that we're living in that that you
found some vacuum or some Gap that junco
came to start solving
yeah so it was very different than what
it is now
um it's like pre-black life matters
um the George Floyd World
um
it's like seven almost years ago right
after
um
the first leaning book
um and just the beginning of those
conversation in the US
um being a more
strategic way
first handful of companies starting to
do stuff
in the space
um
I tried a picture idea back then to like
probably
30 to 50 different VP of HR in Israel
all of them were having a hard time
related to so we're talking about times
where
no one in Israel really cared about it
and especially not as much as it is
today
and
the idea was also very different than
what we did today was way more holistic
solution I think it was a solution only
three people out of Tel Aviv Can Dream
really big about but doesn't necessarily
think about like the execution of it how
you're gonna sell something that big
um think about start trying to sell the
full Salesforce Suite of products on day
one that Salesforce started so
um it was a long journey from where we
were back then and to here obviously but
mostly of understanding on how do you
pencil and sharpen your pencil to
the exact pain point you want to solve
and how do you solve it
um with a longer Vision or when you want
to head but more specifically for how do
you solve and execute in the short two
three years terms um and not how do you
sell Salesforce a day one
awesome so I I'd love for you to
you know I I go to the website and
immediately the first sentence draws a
lot of attention where silver medalists
are matched with a golden opportunities
yeah elaborate on that a little bit for
me that it's a really interesting um
phrase
sure so basically solar medalists and
the tech world in the town acquisition
world are people who gather very last
Finish Line
or is not getting the job so we all know
it right we all recruited before we all
been recruited to specific jobs we we
hear this sentence of it's between you
and another person we're just not sure
yet we need to figure it out and then
one person is being picked and the other
one is a silver medalist right second
place
um
and there are tons of other
really really good opportunities for
those Talent out there so our solution
is basically combining the efforts
between all the companies on the
platform on those silver medalists that
they have that are also other
represented
combine into one pool allowing those
talent to tap into really good
opportunities within other companies
um after not getting the job they
originally applied to
um and that's stuck on like reason
behind it
right and so if we're looking now at the
actual execution of how to go about
solving this problem a lot there's
different people who are using different
different
approaches for execution or what was the
approach that you took
um with the June codes to help change
this landscape
yeah
um so basically we help companies Source
automatically underrepresented
minorities
um I'll share a quick story on how the
idea for the product came up and I think
it will also explain really well the
product
um so we were looking for a data science
back then
um got tons of women applying which is
not the most common application properly
you get to see for data science
and
back in the days where I was Consulting
with one of our angel investors who used
to lead into into Israel and she said oh
you're probably gonna get any Wee Man we
really try to how to recruit data
science that are female and it's really
hard and I say you know what we actually
got tons of them and they're really good
um and she said everyone that you like
that is like really good but you ended
up picking someone else please send them
to into it so everyone that was like
either looking for a part-time job or
wanted salary we couldn't afford we need
a little bit more support than you could
we could afford back then I would email
and say hey I was really impressed I
think it can be a really really good
data science for a tech company but
we are not able to afford it for
whatever reason but intrude is looking
for
more people like yourself go ahead and
apply it into it ended up hiring three
or four out of those
and the rest is history we basically
build out this really small use case
into
um into a scale version of it so every
time they get to the end of the funnel
which is underrepresented get the
opportunity to join a mutual pool and
get offered in other companies
um within the pool
amazing and so what was the you know
from an at the end when you look back at
those initial use cases what really was
the aha moment for you that led you to
understand okay this is actually
something that can scale what what was
the the underlying understanding that's
happening that you were able to solve
that led to this okay now I'm ready to
to go big on this
yeah so two two or maybe three things
that were happening kind of like in
parallel
the realization that what we started
with was a too big of a solution that we
can't sell or at least we don't have the
know-how how how to sell it as a really
small team
second was every time we spoke about dni
we've been rerouted to the conversation
about
we need help with recruiting we need
help resourcing all that you do is great
but we need help with sourcing
and I couldn't figure out a cool techy
way to scale sourcing and the story that
I just shared and I said oh wow if I
could do this at scale
this can be really amazing and take the
other boxes that I just talked about and
I went I took a plane like maybe a week
after that aha moment does talk to it
like 50 different companies in the
states travel between cities pitched
area
and suddenly started to feel what I
didn't feel with the previous idea on
okay people wanted people really like it
it's a good idea people it resonate with
people they feel like they can get value
from it and then
it pushed me to like okay we're doing it
so I pitched it before we even had
anything it was just a concept that I'm
talking to you now about
um
and when I started seeing people say yes
I want in I want in how do I connect how
do I get it I was like okay we're doing
it and then we went ahead and built it
and and it all started
awesome okay so so let's fast forward a
little bit into what junco is today in
today's world
I'm I'm ready for the sort of like the
fast forward here
yeah so we're basically doing what I
just shared this is our platform
more than uh well coming close to 200
companies
um across the US
um anything from like uh still
Manufacturing in Alabama all the way to
like banks credit card companies a lot
of
um kind of like b2c product that we all
um use from Amex to Porsche that all of
us probably use Porsche but just
overtake of the example
um Nike Adidas all those companies
um and uh and it's going great really
and so if you're looking at you know the
way that junko is positioned now talk to
me a little bit about the vision of what
junco is setting out to do in this world
so for me I guess a you know an
entrepreneur's Vision perspective what
is what is the success of junco in your
eyes
yeah so today we're really focused on
the top of the funnel like when
basically a person turns from an
applicant to a candidate and a company
yeah the longer vision is to focus on
how do we make this candidate turning to
an employee and more importantly how do
we retain them in the in the in the
company a lot of companies suffer a lot
from putting a lot of effort and money
in recruiting more black white women
um
latinx those kind of people and veterans
but doesn't know how to keep them in the
company how to make it
like the ROI for this really begin so
for me the longer vision and the success
like you said would be to see like
a full cycle support for companies
around dni
um from the moment that you apply to a
company all the way to you gotta like
got hired and moving forward the fact
that you are
um in how you get promoted how do you
stay in the company and becoming a
valuable asset for the company by
managing diversity not by a gut feeling
or a hunch which is what we see a lot
today but Based on data
now do you see it as a this is your role
and you know throughout the entire
process in certain parts of the process
the entire process
and and and in what ways so what are
what are the main points of intervention
That You observe that that are most
relevant for for junco to to come in to
maximize the potential of the right
candidate getting hired
um in this in such a process
so so along the whole process from like
making sure your job description convert
the right talent and and more
specifically on the represented
minorities making sure that your
interview process is
um inclusive enough making sure that the
question you ask are equal between all
candidates
um and and this is the like spaces that
we want to come in and make sure the
process is equal along the way
um
in what way what what are the tools that
that one would need in order to check
for such inequality or to check that
these candidates are getting Deco
opportunity which would obviously be
beneficial for everybody but how how
does it actually take place
so we connect to
um your output and tracking system the
platform that you manage your recruiting
processes so you can like think about it
as a Salesforce for recruiters
and through this we get all the data we
analyze different patterns of behaviors
and allow us to generate those insights
to our customers not just about the
candidates that we bring in but also all
through the process like their behavior
and how to make it a more inclusive
process
got it okay
main challenges over the years with June
come and you're touching it now it's not
a sensitive subject but it's a
complicated one it's a complicated one
for for probably the same reasons that
it became an issue in the first place so
what what are the different things that
you've had to I guess you know deal with
or go out you know bypass on this
journey here
yeah I think it's learning how to talk
about to talk about this subject
on the one hand in a sensitive way but
also in a business way so looking into
this not just is the fluff but this can
actually generate business kpis good Roi
and how do we measure it so
turning like the the whole thinking of
recruiters from like okay I need more
diverse candidates or underrepresented
candidates to
what do I get from it how does it
benefit my organization so this is one
thing that we had to evolve into our
language and how do we sell and how do
we talk to customers
um obviously the challenge of selling to
a country that I personally didn't grew
up in
um trying to like being the white person
from Israel trying to pitch the black
woman who grew up here in Atlanta
um and kind of like telling her that I
can fix her problems that's that's been
a big challenge we grew since then and
and the team is here is phenomenal but
um
at the same time it's been it's been a
big challenge for any like it's a very
different challenge
for us than any other
cyber security e-commerce startup from
Israel that comes to the US and maybe
doesn't speak the language that well
we're solving a cultural solution which
requires for me and the Israeli seemed
to be way more cultural aware
um so I think this has been like the
most biggest challenges so far
yeah no I think that I think that that
totally makes sense Did You observe any
changes in the landscape over these last
few years you know with covet happening
and black lives matter and everything
else that was going on how has the
landscape shifted from from your
perspective you're obviously in it
you're experiencing it
yeah so I think a lot of things happened
um Trump black lives matters
um
those things really really
boost everything on both ends so
black lives matter is boosted like more
of
the side of the employees that were like
pushing companies to say so what do you
do for like dni how do we improve our
numbers sure please share the numbers
with us we want to see more black latinx
women in the organization and so on and
so forth so this is kind of like the
George Floyd effect but I think also
what I've seen even before that with
Trump being elected
um starting to see more and more CEOs at
the company says okay
we need to take care of the communities
we live in and making sure we embed more
diversity practices into the
organization even if our government
doesn't necessarily push towards it
um that really really shifted the
mindset it's very rare to never happen
that you go on a conversation with
someone they say yeah I don't know if
it's a priority for us
uh which a lot of companies here I guess
with they when they use a lot of stuff
it's the easiest thing to say it's not a
priority for us if you don't want to buy
right
um
but with diversity it's a little bit
harder to say it's not a priority for us
they have other excuses like we all have
on why we're not buying but
you can say it's not a priority year
like every company from like five people
employee company which I get a lot of
reach outs from CEO says hey can you
give us some tips on how to start like
what should we do we don't want to get
to like a Google size of a company and
then realize we have a problem because
then the problem is going to be really
hard to fix we want to fix it that like
right when we start
um all the way up to CEOs
um chros and stuff like that that reach
out and say okay we need we need help we
have a problem
um because we get it both from our board
so a lot of regulations around the board
members
um these days in the US
um where you need to have at least I
think two women who are underrepresented
minorities uh on your board
um which also create pushing to
management and CEOs to become more
diverse as a company so a lot of really
good changes that impacted us in a
positive way
um over the last two or three years
awesome so so what's up next for junco
you know in the in the near future
so first like every company surviving in
this crisis right
um
but uh we're giving a really good
position we're growing um
um as fast as we planned on growing
before this crisis started so I think
we're in a very stable place we raised
recently so financially we're doing
really well
um the
the plan this year is to expand
drastically in the us
um about tripling our current president
in the U.S wow potentially potentially
looking into some acquisition
opportunities in in many different
places
um as what the market creates is like a
lot of companies looking for a new home
basically
um and this this Market became quite
inflated with companies
um obviously not all of them can succeed
um so
this is kind of like for the next year
developing more and more on New York
office
um and our customer facing teams
um as much as our Israeli office is
developed
um so really really exciting time growth
growth growth there's probably our like
biggest Focus for for the next 12 to 18
months that's awesome well I am I'm
gonna continue cheering from the side
and thank you for for the awesome uh you
know conversation on the formation of of
uh junco and then some of the challenges
and the perspectives that you're
bringing with it so it sounds really
phenomenal and I'm really excited to
continue being a fan from the side
hopefully you use the services myself in
my own startup and thank you again for
for the time and the energy
sure thank you so much good to meet you
thank you
[Music]